benvenuti ragazzi a questo nuovo video
di un gioco che era un sacco di tempo
che non portavo sia mai che ho deciso di
iniziare ragazzino scavalca so cascato
in un coso che inizierà una nuova
campagna su mai già totalmente da zero
ed è una cosa molto carina perché stiamo
facendo questa roba su un server dove ci
sono anche tu pressman console march è
un sacco di altre persone che si
costruiranno la casa proprio in questo
server qua quindi io mentre gioco
capiterà che magari per caso
completamente per caso incontro stef
incontra i ragazzi e le mentre io mi
faccio la mia campagna in singolo quindi
alcuni video saranno con loro se ci
becchiamo in giro alcuni video saranno
il singolo come questo ad esempio quindi
è una roba che non si sa se si gioca in
gruppo no dipende da che chiede a chi
incontriamo mentre giochiamo
un'impiegata creare essere il primo in
questo mondo a fare case e rob e quindi
cerchiamo subito un posto dove costruire
la mia e iniziamo la nostra supremazia
sul serio vi dico la roba raga in
apertura che è molto importante e voi lo
sappiate perché sennò poi diventa un
casino cerco di essere chiaro da subito
che su minecraft sono un giocatore old
style
cosa significa silvia che io giocavo a
minecraft quando è uscito e non ho
continuato tanto negli anni nel senso
che nel tempo poi comunque ho smesso di
giocarci non ho giocato le patch e tutte
quante quindi tiro alcune cose non le so
tipo a sé che se vai dice quell'oggetto
io non la società pensa che io ho smesso
di giocare quando c'erano quando hanno
introdotto gli smeraldi ho già non
giocavo più ad esempio anche quando io
giocavo ai tempi gli alberi di funghi
non c'erano quindi per me vederne uno e
mi fa stavo per me è normale aveva
ancora strano comunque la mia tattica
base di minecraft è raccogliere subito
legna manetta finché non arriva il il
buio in modo tale da costruirsi una
casetta in tempo cosa che io faccio
sempre di legno però amico mio devi
smettere
allora questo suo cavallo devo amando
dargli un nome perché adesso questo
cavallo della maestra come siamo essa un
cavallo minecraft la prima cosa che
faccio sarà il mio fidato destriero per
tutta la serie perché guarda come mi
gironzola intorno e non ho fatto ancora
niente ma cosa vuole da me e due ore che
mi guardano ragazzi sembra incredibile
due ore che vi guarda sto cavallo non ho
fatto niente ho iniziato a giocare sto
registrando o vuoi essere la star del
del video non so c'è un cavallo che mi
molesta durante il mio video di mancata
ma va bene quello che sta succedendo ok
va bene ragazzi l'importante non è tanto
il cavallo ma noto andato 26 non so come
chiamarlo da fernando fernando greco
diretto di fernando a posto e lo
chiamiamo fernando chiamiamo fernando
perché da adesso in avanti io mi
costruire una casa anche qua vicino
questi sono sicuri che ce lo vicino e
poi lo lo addestrerà quindi l'obiettivo
di questo video e costruire la casa
maestra il cavallo perché nel prossimo
episodio fernando rimarrà fedele al suo
padrone cioè io quindi grazie mille
fernando della tua compagnia o bel
giorno ma perché mi aspetta porco del
demonio no ragazzi sono remo ragazzo vi
abbia fatto un culo così non ho fatto
niente giorno devo ritrovare dei maiali
che siano in grado di da grazia grazie
ragazzi scusate mi devo veramente magna
vorrei essere vegani minecraft mi fanno
pena però
non posso farlo che sono l'amore che
cos'è sta roba ma lo faceva giungla che
costa ma che marchiò ma fighissimo ci ha
dato anche bene abbiamo dato un bel
server allora io mi farei una casa
proprio qua vicino alla giungla che
quindi sta tra due uomini sono sempre
contrari a mangiarmi la carne così non
costa però in questo momento il mio
bisogno sono schiatto soprattutto perché
sta per diventare nostre probabilmente
quindi vado e soprattutto ragazzi
bisogna trovare l'albero più al non vedo
niente di strano in tutto ciò ma è detto
beh non c'erano in ultima volta che
giocavo anche bello che sei vero
pinuccio allora pinuccio e fernando ce
li abbiamo somministrato anche un
pappagallo che possono essere un cavallo
sicuro credo che gli arcieri non
arrivino gli scheletri non arrivino a
colpire qua teoricamente perché sono
abbastanza in alto però non si sa mai
per non saper né leggere né scrivere io
mi tengo lontano è una è una gara tra me
e i mostri per arrivare a casa mia ma
l'ha rigettata devo tornare a passata in
fretta anche se non vi scompare la roba
non mi ricordo in quanto tempo ti
scompare la roba ragazzi non mi ricordo
neanche se non tu sei morendo due volte
di fila senza averla recuperata poi te
la fa scomparire credo di no
credo che ci sia un time da rispettare
prima che le cose spariscano la sono
arrivato di motor prima ciò conferma
alternata 6 line non milione fernando
scusatemi fernando eccolo lì fernando
stai mi raccomando non ti muovere che
poi ti venga a pigliare
devo tornare a casa mia che sta di qua
ok eccola eccola la vedo
beh la forma è [ __ ] è la forma è
veramente [ __ ] sono tutti i pappagalli
ragazzi mi raccomando state di guardia
perché qui c'è gente cattiva
mi sono abbassato da solo però avevo lo
dettaglio hawaii ea led dove boys ce
l'abbiamo fatta allora vediamo se
scommettere ancora un coso qua perfetto
così uno che sale direttamente
dall'albero si trova tutta la
piattaforma ok e adesso faccio la cosa
che volevo fare prima ovvero qua mettere
una scala ovviamente però uno può
decidere se andare o sopra al piano di
sopra direttamente che è il piano terra
alla fine o al piano meno uno che questo
qua che farò tutto aperto adesso è
chiuso ma farò adesso tutta una linea
aperta in modo tale da poter osservare
anche direttamente da qua questo perché
io osservo i miei nemici anche in stile
medievale quindi abbiamo già piano di
sotto fatto e quindi niente adesso
bisogna corso di una casa di choc ha
però l'importante è che sappiate che qua
io metterò tutta una fila di vetri per
poter osservare tutti quanti di questi
vanno tolti gli omessi solo per poter
creare la base però adesso vanno tolti e
dovrò fondere la sabbia per poter fare
il vetro qua sotto molto importante
allora my boys dovrei aver finito tutto
quello che dovevo fare un pensate se vi
faccio vedere ho fatto il piano di sopra
e quadro di metterci un bel recinto e
quale porte anzi riassetto fare subito
le porte il recinto nomi di come si fa a
cacchio sta roba che tanto ancora river
solo uso per gli stick va bene recinto
come diavolo si fa vado a memoria
no mi sa che era il contrario aspetta
questo se meno male
meno male che culo allora va bene
mettiamolo così ma se gliela farei anche
lo farei anche di un colore diverso c'è
un questo tanto poi non ho abbastanza
pezzi ma dopo di vado a prendere chi se
ne frega però per farvi capire cosa
voglio fare
mettiamo questo one free e poi va beh lo
devo mettere per tuttora tutta la
balconata preparazione metto tre ok poi
ne vado a fare altri questi invece quali
siamo alle porte le porte per forza e la
scala my boys la scala devo usare vista
tutti gli stick non vorrei di una cacata
però
sicuro 21 non basteranno mai diciamo che
la mia idea era di fare dei mega
finestroni anche al piano terra che sono
questi però non giganteschi come il
piano meno uno adesso ragazze che avrete
già fatto tre piani o praticamente fatto
già quasi tutto quello che volevo fare
devo solo poi abbellirla casa però per
come punto di partenza direi che va bene
ragazzi così perfetto
diciamo che se effettivamente dovessi e
costruire una casa sul serio in futuro
magari minimi non faccio io alimenti e
comunque ragazzi a parte gli scherzi
ora che l'ho fatta [ __ ] ma che roba è la
casa di partenza cioè non è la casa
stupida quella che fanno cioè quelli per
iniziare sta già qualcosa e poi metterò
i vetri tutto figo per partire direi che
non è male devo fare
non ce la faccio in questo episodio
ragazzi a fare cose di fernando ma chi
se ne frega però la casa l'ho già fatta
qua a fare un bello spiazzo per fernando
devo mettere poi tutte le scale questo
lo farò nei prossimi episodi ragazzi
intanto vado su a crearmi la cesta
perché una volta che michero
l'accertamento tutto metto tutto che
madonna metto tutto dentro diciamo che
posso concludere in serenità vero
continua a spararmi in serenità
l'episodio così lo coltiva prossima
volta con gli oggetti
nel posto giusto ecco perché perché ho
iniziato a disintegrarsi il pavimento
perché è fatto di schifo beh allora lo
faccio con legno chissenefrega
non c'è proprio pavimento ragazzo
classiche sono cascato almeno fino a
questo punto ci arrivo e poi uso la
scarpa pian piano la faccio meglio era
però almeno almeno per arrivarci
comunque si è disintegrato il pavimento
è chiara a vita stanno solo anche di ciò
abbastanza legna per chiuderlo però
vabbè l'importante è averlo capito e non
rifare questo errore dunque ok ma non
sapevo che si sgretolasse fallimento
perché lo fa
sarà un nome forse perché l'altra perché
ho tagliato il legno all'albero sarà
quello quanta merda roma ricordavo sta
roba
non devo toccare il tronco principale
dell'albero sono mai stata tutta lettera
non ho più legna cacchio devo andare a
prendere anche quella di ultimare piano
di sotto e chissenefrega dai per adesso
l'importante è che ho capito il problema
così lo risolvo allora siamo qua abbiamo
le scale mettiamo anche le scale per
andare al piano ancora di sopra allora
ragazzi io farei direi di concludere
quale episodio perché per adesso ci
siamo manca ovviamente devo aggiustare
qua sotto perché mi si sgretoli il
pavimento in una maniera incredibile ma
per adesso dovremmo essere abbastanza
tranquilli abbiamo tutto l'unica cosa
che effettivamente manca che faccio
prima di concludere la cesta dove
mettere la roba perché i ragazzi
la cosa importante che la gente visto
che questo qua è un server e qui ci
giocano i ragazzi non mi devono [ __ ]
le robe e quindi le metto qua perché
successivamente poi farò ovviamente
delle spedizioni coi ragazzi quindi
troviamo diamanti robe mettiamo tutto
qua però questa è la mia cesta mettiamo
tutta la roba qua dentro ci sono sicuri
che non la perdiamo ci vediamo in un
prossimo episodio dove magari proverò a
fare il posto a fernando e soprattutto
devo andare a vedere se fernando mi
vuole come compagni ma credo di sì visto
che mi ha seguito fino adesso metterà i
vetri alla casa ultime rho per bene la
casa però per adesso la stiamo facendo
non mi sembra niente male questi vedere
al basso ci arrivo lì se mi tuffo
ovviamente non ci arriverò mai non c'è
una puzza anche la maledetta devo
crearla volevo solo vedere come si vede
la casa dal basso tanto ho posato tutti
gli oggetti quindi stick a chi posso
anche tentare di buttarmi tanto se muoio
niente a mike ness very nice
immaginate di ci siano veti
al posto dei buchi perché mancano
ovviamente devo fare con la sabbia ma ci
metto un po comunque giuliana prossime
bisogno i ragazzi vediamo se lo faremo
anche con stessi agli altri e andiamo
sicuramente a catturare il nostro amico
fernando come fosse un pokémon facciamo
diventare il mio pikachu non perdetevi i
prossimi episodi
un bacino lasciato un bel commento e
come al solito ragazzi
[Musica]